[Applause]
okay good morning thank you all so much
for being here Administrator Andrew
wheeler and I are so pleased to announce
a major step forward in president
Trump's plan to help ensure that more
Americans have access to safer more
affordable and cleaner new cars that
meet their family's needs two and a half
years ago President Trump spoke with
auto workers in Michigan and said that
we would review and revise the last
administration's unattainable fuel
economy regulations those rules were
making cars more expensive and impeding
safety because consumers were being
priced out of newer safer vehicles our
team of experts have been jointly
working together conducting a long
thoughtful and detailed review of these
rules and today's action is an important
downpayment on the President's
commitment the one national program that
we are announcing today will ensure that
there is one and only one set of
national fuel economy standards as
Congress mandated and intended no state
has the authority to up out of the
nation's rules and no state has the
right to impose its policies on
everybody else in our whole country to
do otherwise harms consumers and damages
the American economy it should be noted
that this rule only applies to fuel
economy it will not affect California's
ability to refocus its efforts on
fighting the worst air pollution in the
country and comply with existing
regulations
in the coming weeks we'll also be
publishing the second part of the safe
vehicles rule which will set new
national standards fuel economy
standards and while the second part is
not yet finalized I can say that the
updated standards will be reasonable and
for the sake of the American worker the
whole entire workforce American by I
mean let me say that over again and for
the sake of American workers American
car buyers and the economy the rule will
not force automakers to spend billions
of dollars developing cars that
consumers do not want to buy or drive
the new standards will help make new
vehicles more affordable and will ensure
that the American consumer still has a
variety of choices when selecting
vehicles that best suits their family's
needs the new standards will save our
country billions of dollars they will
strengthen our domestic manufacturing
base by adding millions of new car sales
and of course supporting good-paying
American jobs and most importantly
because newer cars are safer the
standards will save thousands of lives
and prevent tens of thousands of serious
injuries so with today's one national
program rule the administration is
standing up for all Americans their
needs and their right to choose we will
not let political agendas in a single
state be forced upon the other 49 and we
will always put safety first thanks so
much
thank you very much secretary Chao it is
now my privilege to introduce the
administrator of the Environmental
Protection Agency administrator Andrew
wheeler thanks to administrator wheelers
leadership EPA is delivering on
president Trump's agenda to grow the
economy and improve lives while at the
same time protecting the environment and
human health today's action is the
latest in a long line of a very
important regulatory reforms at EPA and
I know that he will continue to keep me
and my team very busy please join me in
welcoming administrator in you really
thank you and I want to thank your whole
team Thank You secretary Chao I want to
thank your whole team in particularly
with our teams together work long and
hard over the last months to get this
proposal where it is and I want to thank
you and for the professionalism of your
of your staff and everything that we've
done together
president Trump promised the American
public that his administration would
address and fix the current fuel economy
and greenhouse gas emission standards
today we are delivering on a critical
element of the President's commitment
BPA and d-o-t are issuing a final action
that will establish one set of national
fuel economy standards let me be clear
our goal from the beginning was a
50-state solution
I met with carb three times since taking
the lead at EPA over a year ago but
despite our best efforts we cannot reach
a solution we embrace federalism in the
role of states but federalism does not
mean that one state can dictate
standards for the entire country to
borrow from Louisiana Attorney General
Jeff Landry cafe does not stand for
California assumes federal empowerment
so we are moving forward with one
national fuel economy standard we
believe the law is clear no state has
the authority to opt out of national
fuel economy standards and no state has
the authority to set its own fuel
any standards that impact human safety
the environment and commerce for the
rest of the country one national
standard will provide much-needed
certainty to the automotive industry and
it sets the stage for president Trump's
ultimate objective a final safe rule
that will save lives and strengthen the
economy by reducing the price of new
vehicles and helping more Americans
purger purchase newer cleaner and safer
cars in trucks this is good for public
safety good for the economy and good for
the environment here's how today's
action works under the energy policy and
conservation act or Epke do tea sets
cafe standards Epcot's presely provides
that the federal government regulates
fuel economy not the states since
there's a direct scientific link between
a car's greenhouse gas emissions and its
fuel economy d-o-t is determining that
Epke permit preempts state GHG and zero
emission vehicle programs
that's one basis on which EPA intends to
withdraw the 2013 waiver for
California's state GHG and Zev programs
separate and apart from that EPA is
withdrawing the waiver based on our
interpretation and application of one of
the criteria for denying a waiver does
the state need its standards to meet
quote compelling and extraordinary
conditions understood in its origin and
context the California waiver authority
exists because California has uniquely
bad problems with smog forming
pollutants there's a direct and tight
link between one California cars and
their emissions of criteria pollutants
to the local concentrations of those
emissions and three the impacts they
have on California due to the state's
extraordinary perfect storm of features
like population traffic temperature when
ocean currents and topography but for
greenhouse gases the tight and direct
link isn't there California cars have no
closer link to California climate
impacts than do cars on the road in
Japan or anywhere else in the
world and California's climate impacts
are not extraordinarily distinct from
those felt in other states in the same
way that its smog impacts are it makes
sense the Congress carved out waiver
authority for California to address its
unique local problems it does not make
sense to use that authority to try to
address national and global issues like
greenhouse gas emissions it's time to
put California's waiver back in its box
the Box that Congress always intended it
to stand California's unique
extraordinary criteria air pollutant
issues today's action does not impact a
number of other California programs
including its low emission vehicle
program designed to address harmful
ozone and other forms of air pollution
this will allow the state to focus on
addressing its air quality problems and
finally achieving compliance with EPA's
national ambient air quality standards
California has the worst air quality in
the United States it has 80 to
non-attainment areas and 34 million
people living in areas that do not meet
the knacks standards that's more than
twice as many people as any other state
in the country we hope that the state
will focus on these issues rather than
trying to set fuel economy standards for
the entire country today's action also
clears the way for our final safe rule
our proposed safe rule reflects what we
believe is the right approach to
national fuel economy standards right
for Public Safety and the environment
now we get four reasons why first
revising the standards will reduce the
price of new vehicles the average
sticker price of a new vehicle reached
thirty nine thousand five hundred in the
first half of this year this is simply
out of reach for many American families
the current trajectory of the standards
is one of the factors driving costs
higher in order to comply with the Obama
standards automakers need to sell many
more electric vehicles by some counts
they will need to produce lineups that
are 50% electric or more over the next
seven years
however electric vehicles
cost $12,000 more to make than the
average vehicle according to Mackenzie
analysis those costs are passed on to
the consumers which is one reason why
electric vehicles are still despite
billions of dollars in subsidies less
than 2% of new vehicle sales but one way
for automakers to meet the standards is
to lower the price of electric vehicles
and raise the price of other more
popular vehicles such as SUVs and trucks
in other words American families are
paying more for SUVs and trucks so that
automakers can sell v's at a cheaper
price it's one thing for the American
public to directly subsidize electric
vehicles through tax incentives it's
another thing to use the nation's
vehicle emission standards to prop up a
product that has minimal impact on the
environment and only the wealthy can
afford of the roughly 57 thousand
households that receive the evie tax
credit in 2016 nearly 80 percent made
over $100,000 if these people want to
buy an Eevee I think they can afford one
without asking low and middle-income
Americans to help pay for it compared to
keeping the 2012 standards in place the
preferred option and our safe proposal
would reduce the price of new vehicles
by thousands of dollars which leads
directly to my second point revising the
standards and reducing the price of new
vehicles will save lives
research shows the passengers are more
likely to be killed in older vehicles
compared to newer ones according to the
Nets a study a driver of a vehicle 8 to
11 years old that's the vehicle not the
driver is nearly 20% more likely to be
fatally injured than the driver of a
vehicle that was three years old or less
the driver of a vehicle that's 12 to 14
years old is 32 percent more likely to
die in an accident and a driver of a
vehicle that's 15 to 17 years old is 50%
more likely to be fatally injured by
revising the standards in reducing the
price of new vehicles we will help
Americans purchase newer and safer cars
and trucks we estimate that our proposed
revised standards to the safe rule could
save thousands of lives
third we are revising the standards in
aim
that will have a negligible impact on
the environment compared to the current
standards here are two important facts
that the public needs to know first even
the most stringent vehicle standards
imaginable will have only a minimal
impact on global temperatures according
to the Obama administration's 2012
analysis even a much more stringent
version of version of their rule than
the one that they eventually finalized
would have only lowered global
temperatures by two one hundredths of a
degree Celsius by 2100 so it's important
to put things in context we're talking
about changes in the hundreds of a
degree Celsius by 2100 here's the second
fact most automakers cannot comply with
the trajectory of the current standards
for model year 2016 domestic passenger
vehicle manufacturers paid more than 77
million dollars for non-compliance and a
model year 2017 only three large
manufacturers complied based on the
technology levels of their vehicles
alone most large manufacturers used
banked credits along with technology
improvements to maintain compliance the
most recent co2 data on credits and the
shortfall between the fleet and the cafe
compliance suggests that this figure may
rise dramatically to the due to the
increasing stringent C of the Obama
standards for example the total
shortfall and cafe credits for model
year 2018 is the equivalent of almost
1.3 billion dollars more than 10 times
higher than the equivalent shortfall for
model year 2011 which was just over 100
million this begs the question why keep
the standards that automakers can only
comply with through credits and paying
fees we believe that the changes are
needed and that the SAF proposal set
forth our view of what changes are
appropriate and because our rule remove
certain credits and fees our standards
would have a negligible impact on the
environment compared to the current
standards fourth and finally revising
the standards will help more Americans
purchase newer cleaner and safer cars
the average age of vehicles on the road
today is a record high of 12 years in
1990 the average age was eight years
either consumers cannot afford the price
of new vehicles or they are not
interested in purchasing certain types
of new vehicles either way the lack of
fleet turnover creates a host of
problems the most important of which is
passenger safety by revising the
standards we will reduce the price of
new vehicles and as prices fall
president Trump's vision becomes reality
more Americans will be able to purchase
newer cleaner and safer vehicles
vehicles they actually want to buy the
president knows that accelerating fleet
turnover is good for the auto industry
it's good for consumers it's good for
public safety and it's good for the
environment thank you for your time
today and for your attention and thank
you for joining us today
[Applause]
thank you very much administrator
wheeler I would also now like to take
this opportunity to invite congressman
from the first victory of California
congressman Lamar fo for your remarks
sir thank you and thank you very much
I'm delighted to be here today for this
subject matter especially in my real
life I'm a farmer in Northern California
and I'm very in touch with our
constituents on what their automotive
needs are and what we're really talking
about the bottom line here is auto
choice people in this country still like
to have choices and when I saw this
Obama era mandate coming down the line a
few years ago and thinking how realistic
is it by the year 2025 all automobiles
in the fleet would have to average 55
miles per gallon I can't even think of
what a 55 mile per gallon vehicle looks
like right now especially what that
means for the average buyer you know is
that our mom need to get her kids to
school and off to do the other chores or
a dad or people just might want to have
a vehicle with a little bit of room in
it because they got some guys my size
right so I I think that what we're
really seeing is that this
administration and I really want to be
very thankful to secretary Chao
administrator
assistant administrator it's all on
listening to the people of this
situation California Air Resources Board
for my constituents they plead with me
and my state legislative colleagues to
say can we have some relief from their
latest dream they have each month or
each six months on a new mandate I have
legislation to make it for example less
costly to buy full-size trucks for
people to use in agriculture you if
you've got it a truck brought it
everything you have has been brought by
a truck and so we want to update trucks
have them burn a little cleaner a little
better but there's a punitive tax a
federal excise tax any over 12 to 15
thousand dollars on top of all the rest
of that's acts for buying a new truck
update with if we want to incentivize
that we need to give people what they
need to have the affordability for it
seems
goes with automobiles Administrator
wheeler really hit it out of the park
from where I was sitting that this comes
down to subsidizing other people into
these electric vehicles and we know
standing alone electric vehicles do not
pay and the electricity comes from
somewhere it doesn't just magically
happen nearby I have a lot of the power
lines running from my district from
hydroelectric plants and other plants
many miles through my rice fields to go
to the urban area so people can feel
good about themselves of plugging into
their electric car so the reality is the
better we can make our gasoline-powered
vehicle is the more efficient and the
tailpipe is still clean on all these
cars no matter what their size with
their mpg is so we're really talking
about as we're chasing co2 numbers here
so the reality is is that our
manufacturers are making better cars
than ever on efficiency on aerodynamics
and cars that you like to drive I'm a
car enthusiast myself and one of the
manufacturers I'm not very happy with
with cutting a deal with California
going behind the backs it's
administration who is looking out for
consumer choice in this country so at
this point I hope we can keep going
straight ahead and I will support the
efforts have been straighter wheeler dpa
I never thought I'd be saying that a lot
about that but and secretary Chao and
right home in my own district we're just
now putting out a 54 thousand acre
forest fire if you want to talk about
air quality year after year after year
hundreds of thousands of acres of forest
burn in the West and I know I realize
that's a different building down the
street with the USDA and our Forest
Service and they're working on making
things better and also this migrant
migratory emissions that come from other
areas that affect our state too so
forcing us into our little caves and our
little tiny cars is not going to change
the situation for my constituents for
Californians and certainly to have the
state of California and the California
Air Resources Board dictatorial policies
going towards the rest of the 50 states
again my people plead for relief from
hard to say let's put reasonable
regulations back in place so I hope this
administration does not give up at all
on fighting carb and because that's all
California seeds wants to do is fight us
here in Congress and this administration
every day they think up a new lawsuit a
new thing to come after as we're just
trying to make jobs happen in this
country not in China all these things we
have to be anja factored to make these
electric cars ago
why aren't we mining the materials in
this country we need four batteries for
this high-tech apparatus we need across
the board instead we expect other
countries to supply it to us supply the
manufacturing supply their raw materials
so we're on the right track because we
can do it better more efficiently even
more ecologically soundly in this
country than anywhere in the world if
we're allowed to do it so again my
thanks secretary mr. ed wheeler
assistant administrator it's all in
secretary Chao and everybody in this
room here today that is being part of
this to give us our choices back for our
constituents for what they need not what
they need in Sacramento thank you
[Applause]